make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay what's going on guys this is Rob
and you're gonna have to bear with me on
this with regards to probably some echo
maybe some background noise I'm in
Columbus now and I am not really in a
sound treated space so I'm just kind of
in a kitchen recording this audio so
yeah anyway so we're picking up with
expedition number five right we still
need to kind of get back into the swing
of things you know cover like x-force
and Excalibur and all that kind of stuff
and we'll get back into that but for
right now we're we're taking it
relatively easy this week and we're
gonna cover x-men issue number five now
what this does and this is something
that I kinda need to clarify in previous
videos I feel like I was confusing
children of the vault with children of
tomorrow and I probably was the children
of tomorrow were from the Ultimate
Universe right and then and we cover
that during a Jonathan Hickman's
was it the ultimate so that we covered
that you'll find the link to that down
in the description it's not super
important to this video just kind of
clarifying things but the idea was that
Reed Richards at least ultimate universe
Reed Richards had constructed a city
that basically allowed time to pass
differently and the result was that what
this did is it created a kind of space
whereby he could essentially create life
watch that life evolved with rapid
acceleration right so time passed
totally different in that area with this
with the the children of the vault that
was Mike Harry back in 2006 right now
really you have the what was called the
the supernovas storyline that really
kind of introduced the children of the
vault back in x-men vol 2 issue number
198 I think it was and and basically we
we kind of got this a little bit of a
story with him and then they were almost
never referenced again after that right
now a lot of that was because of what
Joe Quesada and and all those guys were
doing you know like like Rick Remender
and Craig Hale and Chris Yost and Ed
Brubaker and all those guys really kind
of like reworking the x-men mythos post
house of him and so because then it was
kind of like alright so let's just kind
of see what happens and so I was really
focusing more on reducing the population
of mutants and then focusing on on those
particular stories but for Mike Carey
supernovas event what we ended up
finding out was that somewhere along the
line there was this this giant space
much like what we saw later on with
Jonathan Hickman's ultimate there was
basically this kind of City this sort of
vault that was constructed and time
passed differently in the vault and it
basically allowed individuals were
allowed at you know allowed kind of a
creation of these children and the idea
behind this is that these children would
evolve over the course of 6,000 years it
was something along those lines
basically they would exit the vault at a
time when humans and mutants no longer
existed on earth and there would
basically be these kind of post humans
that were
we kind of take over the landscape the
result of this is that by the mecha
nation of Sabretooth in the House of M
event itself they ended up being woken
up early and so when they did only five
of them showed up instead of the
thousands that were supposed to and you
basically got the supernova storyline
now for how this pertains to this what
we end up doing here is picking up with
a girl named Sarafina
now Serafina was one of the children of
the vault and really the most notable in
the supernovas event because the kind of
power she possessed whereas she
demonstrated the ability to dominate the
minds of others she was also able to
shield herself from telepathic detection
as well as a cerebro right so she was
basically invisible to the mental eye
I'm pretty sure it was a naked eye as
well but nobody really knew that she was
inside the the x-men mansion but uh what
we end up having here is basically
Serafina who's essentially running for
her life after you know basically
haven't been discovered during the
original house of X and powers of X
story with the the orchid spaces so on
and so forth and how many somehow
managed to arrive back here on earth and
then basically taking off that you know
she's fleeing for a life and then takes
over the minds of a couple people and
basically says stop that man from
chasing me only for us to find out that
it's wolf rain right now the reason why
this matters is because the children of
the vault or as much an enigma to the
x-men as anything else and so while the
x-men do view them as a credible threat
they almost are they also know almost
nothing about them except for the fact
that whenever they leave the vault it's
always done in groups and that's
basically it don't really know anything
about the children of the ball and it's
kind of a desire to understand what's
going on as well as determine whether or
not they're a credible threat and so the
results of this is that of course these
guys run up on Wolverine Wolverine
doesn't really kill him he just kind of
incapacitates them and then goes on the
hunt for the girl only for her to enter
the vault and initially when windless
this story was released I was looking
through the issue I didn't really know
I've recognized Serafina I didn't really
know what I was going on here and it's
not until Wolverine basically chimes in
with the x-men and then asks are you
guys still there and it's like yes we're
here and it's like she took off into the
vault like we can't find it right we
can't trace we can't track her and we
can't go in there now the reason why
this is important is because the vault
does have a physical seal right it does
have a physical entrance but it also has
a time sure basically meaning if you
don't if your body doesn't exist to the
resident huh more or less like if it
doesn't really match the access code to
get into the vault then essentially it
could kill you right I could it could
destroy you and so you kind of have to
be designed or engineered in such a way
to where you can enter the vault right
so it's like knowing the passcode to be
able to get in and so because of that
what the x-men basically need are a
group of people who can adapt to pretty
much any circumstance and then
enter into the vault itself now one
other thing to point out here is that
this vault is basically housed by a
gigantic Sentinel now the reason why
this matters is because this is
essentially master mold but it's not
just any master mold it's the wild
master mold this is one of the reasons
why Jonathan Hickman's x-men run is so
cool because it really kind of taps into
a lot of the things that were going on
now the reality of this is that with
this giant vault more or less this giant
Sentinel this was part of my carriage
run right this is where the the children
of the ball basically retreated to once
it was all said and done but the the
Giants said well here this this giant
master mold is essentially a wild
Sentinel and this was introduced during
Grant Morrison's es for extinction
storyline right with Cassandra Nova this
idea that somewhere along the line that
ball of our Trask had basically
engineered these kind of wild
experimental signals but they were never
actually used the signals that existed
in this space on this island these wild
sentinels they were used by Cassandra
Nova to wipe out 16 million mutants on
the island of Genosha right so that's
where all that comes from this guy
master mold was the one who was
basically engineering and creating this
by just kind of manufacturing these
things now as far as we're aware the
master mold isn't really functional
anymore it's just kind of a giant shell
of a monster in and the vault kind of
resides within but what this does it
really kind of allows us to basically
pick up with when an approved organism
enters into the bowl and what it does
the ball basically scans them it says
like do we recognize you do we not
recognize you if we recognize you we
welcomed you as a friend and you're able
to enter the vault presumably if we do
not recognize you you're treated as an
enemy and so what it does is it jumps
over to the x-men this is one of the
things that's really kind of important
here because the sort of establishes how
the vault works and so far is time
flowing differently now we're not really
given a ratio right we're not really
told for every two days that passes like
a hundred years pass inside the vault
right it's just time passes differently
totally different from from the way time
normally works here outside of the vault
in the real world and so as a result of
that it's one of those things where
telepathy and and none of the technology
of the x-men can penetrate the vault but
they need to know what's going on inside
of there and so what they've done is
they've assembled a group they've
assembled Darwin sink and x-23 now the
reason why this is important is because
Darwin is a lot of you guys probably
know is a mutant whose ability allows
him to adapt to any situation right so
if you were to put him in a pod and then
just shoot him out into space then his
body would adapt to the ability to
breathe in space if you put him
underwater his body would adapt to the
ability to breathe underwater which
coincidentally is actually how he first
discovers his powers
it's one of these things while you put
him in a room with toxic gas he'll
develop the ability to basically filter
that gas out of his body and then
survive in that that particular space
the guy is it'll mega level mutant
because of that right there's no real
conceivable way to actually kill Darwin
with that you also have sink and sink is
an old-school character right sink
originally debuted the older x-men vol 2
comics in the early 1990s and then went
on to become one of the original members
of Generation X now in Generation X
issue number 70 he ended up dying and so
he's really been out of the landscape of
Marvel Comics since 2005 so for about 19
years he'd basically been gone uh him
being brought back as part of those
resurrections that were done by the five
right that's what Jonathan Hickman has
really been doing with the five is
basically resurrecting all the mutants
who have died but but Hickman's not
really doing it arbitrarily he's kind of
staging it out right like no is there a
reason for this mutant to be here if
there is resurrect them if not leave
them dead until we need them and then we
resurrect them right so sinkers a
character who can basically duplicate
the powers of pretty much any other
mutants and then of course you've got
Laura Kinney x-23 with her healing
factor and so because of this what
they're basically told is you guys have
all been chosen because you can all
adapt to pretty much any particular
circumstance the the healing factor of
x-23 would allow her to basically heal
from the time she R ride the idea the
time she would try to cut off their
access she can kind of push her way
through it darwin in sync can really
adapt you know sync can adapt to the to
the powers of x-23 so he can enter and
then darwin can just automatically adapt
to whatever particular situation he
needs now the other part of this is that
the you know aside from Sarafina the
other five members of children of the
vault are basically dead right like it
seems like you know for her for the most
part pretty much everybody's dead but
the other four members are dead right so
uh Sangre pero it was a goo yeah I'm not
too sure how you pronounce that that
name and in Frey go they were all
basically dead except for Sarafina she's
the only one who's still there and so
with her basically returning it's okay
she's here you know she basically
returned to the vault now and then from
that point the ball starts going through
and saying okay it's time to start
upgrading people you know from there the
vault really kind of does exactly what
the x-men have been doing which is
restoring those individuals who have
died and then in turn upgrading them
right so preparing them for this new
kind of threat that the x-men seem to
represent and so what the x-men do is
they launch an attack seemingly on two
fronts
the first one is basically going to
serve the purpose of kind of being a
distraction the false the boss defense
system will kick in when it recognizes a
threat
and so the x-men will show up and
they'll presents themselves as a
credible threat the vault will see them
that way and then the vault will launch
defense mechanisms but what the vault
will do is focus on them and not focus
on the kind of wet work team or less
right the secret team in the sense of
x-23 Darwin em and sink and so as they
make their way to that location they're
able to of course access and get into
the vault but once they get inside this
space the issue they run into is of
course all all communication is
basically cut off right it's like a it's
like a closed biome in a lot of ways the
vault is akin to like a different
dimension right like if they had entered
into the dimension of asgard then like
access to any really to any real
telepathic connection from Xavier would
essentially be cut off right or like
traveling to a different universe or
something along those lines
it really is completely self-contained
and completely cut off from everything
and everyone else because by being a
system that basically uses a kind of
time manipulation basically means it is
almost out of phase out of sync with the
existing main Marvel Universe the issue
with this is that once the the team
basically enters into the vault then it
turns into okay the vault sees them as a
credible threat right basically the
vault has been quote-unquote
contaminated it doesn't know who these
guys are it doesn't know what their
powers are and so it automatically
begins launching its defense system and
so what you end up having is much later
roughly about three months in five days
after the x-men enter the vault and when
they get in there Cyclops starts talking
to what what looks like Charles Xavier
watching everything go down and when he
says like how long has it been of course
you know Xavier whoever this is says you
know three months and five days and so
how long has it been inside of the vault
and it's roughly 537 years have passed
inside that vault now what this means is
that when it comes to these characters
this is actually a really really smart
move by Hickman if what Jonathan Hickman
wants to do is change the powers of X 23
or change the powers of sync or change
the powers of Darwin right to like
elevate them and make them more powerful
than they were before
this is the way to do it because what he
would basically say here is that they've
evolved it would just say over the
course of the last 500 years their
powers have evolved right so it's like
if they lived for five hundred years in
the real world so over three months they
probably could have gotten stronger
faster maybe their powers are more
potent maybe the healing factor of X 23
is more efficient maybe the powers of
Darwin are more extreme and what he can
and can't copy maybe now is molecular
manipulation we don't really know we
won't really know until the exit from
the vault but it's kind of Cyclops sort
of looking at himself and saying what
the hell was I thinking by sending them
in there
but with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end if you
are new here two comments explain to
make sure you guys have the sub button
to become part of the rob4 if you guys
enjoy this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]
okay I want to give a shout out to Kyle
be David Joseph been John h aj Matt in
Jeff are John H lean and mean which is
an awesome name Jason see Austin s
Austin a Joey M Steven Z Austin be Adam
K and Genesis 9:6 team you remember guys
you can send me messages and I'll run
off whatever your message is at the end
of the video so long there's nothing
crazy but if you want to put a message
in there send me an email Rob at Robert
Jefferson calm and if you're one of
these people who get shoutouts
then I will tack it in there and yeah
they should watch you guys
[Music]
[Music]